it's either some sort of initiation or
something but it's like
yeah they'll put their finger on the
edge i can't even i have a carpal tunnel
so i can't even do it but like if i did
that and then they have nail polish on
it's just bad nail
all right what what's the why what
what's the matter i was just curious
i don't know
i just i don't like that you have a bad
nail you have a bad nail
and i like the nail that's funny yeah
yeah what do you mean having a bad nail
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's had
a ton of athlete's foot on his left foot
for years right saying that you should
pee on it in the shower no he doesn't
want to heal it because he finds it to
be like a very um
it's a hobby for him so he likes to
scratch it and then i had athlete's foot
for like a year and it does feel really
good especially at night
it's so good you know what i'm talking
about exactly how good it is and i
understand because i love having lice
[Laughter]
wait what i i loved having lice i loved
like popping the little things in my
fingers it was a fun thing as a kid okay
would gladly somebody please give me
life so but
for real for real that's [ __ ] crazy
like that's one of the craziest things
yeah
it's not i've ever heard of it i mean
what do you say imagine you're laying
next to your wife and you hear pop
pop
because they have to they use this fine
food at home
oh my god here we go you guys it's so
great it's underrated i promise oh my
god
get on board
this is the most insane coat this is a
cope
this is text like guys this is actually
cool as hell no it's the worst thing
ever look at that
yeah and when someone is just like doing
this to your hair and it's just great oh
my gosh
my head is itchy right now for some
reason
it's underrated i think you guys are
missing out but here's what i wanted to
tell you that he would scratch his
athlete's foot so much that it got under
that particular nail that you see
and then and then
one more one more transference
he then touched me and then i got jock
itch
surprise
what do you want bobby
now is that better or worse than lice
that's better thank you license
thank you
thank you crazy lice is crazy lice is
crazy now that's [ __ ] and the reason
why it's crazy is because you don't hear
it a lot anymore it's like somebody
dying from smallpox you don't hear it
right
it's like an older thing right so it's
like you know we don't even know what
lice is like on our heads because we
have water and shampoo right
when did you get lice
philippines
when i was younger in the philippines
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay but
so there wasn't as much of us welcome
you back into my life
like everybody in the philippines was
like
i mean yeah
it became something we did as a family
it's a certain thing it's so weird
i know each other's hair but i'm really
not doing it
no no we may
not know what it's like maybe it is cool
where like two years ago in new york oh
it's the worst you have to think about
it every night you have to burn
everything yeah i got rid of everything
i did they [ __ ] you up
yeah not really but like mentally oh wow
it like [ __ ] you up no i'm not saying
it was like i was
ugh but like
like i still look for bed bugs now like
it [ __ ] you up how do you know you have
them
uh
if they're not biting on